and to make the case for rejecting the
calls both of those who would prefer to
plunge the country into the uncertainty
and economic self-harm of no deal and of
those who would seek to undo the
referendum decision and in doing so fuel
a narrative of betrayal which would
undermine the broad consent on which our
democratic politics is based
I give ways the Honourable gentleman
just during the recently the Chancellor
said that backing the promises deal will
be better for the country than remaining
in the EU yet back in February 2016
during the referendum campaign he said a
yes vote would lead to very significant
uncertainty and would have a chilling
effect on the economy what informations
our Chancellor got that he could share
with the rest of us that has caused him
to have such a fundamental change of
opinion well mr. speaker I've always
recognized that leaving the EU will have
an economic cost what the deal the Prime
Minister has negotiated does is minimize
that economic cost we have a nation that
is divided on this issue and I
fundamentally believe that we have to
bring the country back together in order
to succeed as a country in the future
and this deal offers a sensible
compromise which protects our economy
but delivers on the decision of the
British people in the referendum and my
judgment is that if we want to maximize
the chances of our nation being
successful in the future this is the
right way to go by tomorrow I'm very
grateful to my right honourable friend
did he subscribe to the statement in the
2017 general election manifesto from the
Conservative Party that no deal would be
better than a bad deal
yes yes mr. speaker and as I've said in
this house many times at the beginning
of this process there were people inside
the European Union who were
contemplating a punishment deal for the
United Kingdom a deal designed to punish
us for having the audacity to decide to
leave the European Union clearly we
could not have accepted such terms for
our departure
I'll give way one more time to malleable
friends and I make a little bit the
transfer mentioned a speech noti'm I
want to be could explain what no deal is
because my understanding it's at the
rest of the world trace on WTO rules
with independent free trade agreement so
there is no such thing is no deal is
there because everybody but if we did
leave and I don't buy the language
crashing out we would trade on WTO rules
that's not no deal surely yes mr.
speaker it is no deal and and as I shall
say later on in my speech if we did
leave the European Union without a deal
we would actually be the only advanced
economy in the world trading with the
European Union on pure WTO terms with no
facilitation agreements whatsoever and
in my view that would be a very very bad
outcome for the United Kingdom
I'll give way to the right honourable
gentleman and then I will make some
pregnancy they came before giving way
and I agree with him that they will
inevitably be an economic penalty from
leaving the EU does he agree that having
to comply with lots of rules set by the
EU over which we will no longer have any
say which will be the position under
with a drawl agreement but that is part
of the economic penalty that we will
suffer mr. speaker it depends very much
on what those rules are the rules around
the the goods a key the part of you
regulation that deals with goods are
very stable and have been for many many
years we know that our manufacturers in
this country will follow will continue
to follow you rules on goods whether we
choose to adopt those rules or not so I
think the economic price of having such
rules would be very small in other areas
for example in financial services where
rules are changing very rapidly where
there's a great dynamism in the system
there could be much greater dangers for
us in being locked in to following rules
over which we had no influence and
that's why the deal that we're putting
before the house proposes a very
different way forward for goods than it
does for services and particularly
financial services Mr Speaker I have
observed this process at close quarters
for two-and-a-half years and I'm
absolutely clear about one thing this
deal is the best deal to exit the EU
that is available or that is going to be
available the idea that there is an
option of renegotiating at the eleventh
hour is simply a delusion we need to be
honest with ourselves the alternatives
to this deal are no deal or no grexit
either will leave us a fractured a
fractured society and a divided nation
only the compromise of this negotiated
deal delivering on the referendum result
by leaving the EU ending free movement
of people and reasserting our sovereign
control over our laws while at the same
time maintaining the closest possible
trade security and cultural links with
the European Union to protect our jobs
our living standards and our values only
that compromise can allow our country to
move on only that compromise can bring
us back together after brexit is
delivered and we should remember the
lesson of history that divided nations
are not successful nations they give way
to my honourable friend it's important
that we have a deal that it's not just
only good for the economy but it's also
one that brings our country together and
the deal on the table is one that offers
that and it's one that we should move
forward with and imagine
we agree with my honorable friend and
that is the central theme of what I
shall say to the House today
yes leaving the European Union has a
cost but going back on the decision of
the British people would also have an
enormous cost for our country I give way
to mountable friend you very much does
my right honorable friend agree that
uncertainty is bad for our economy and
very bad for businesses yes mr. speaker
and we are already paying a price and
have paid a price for the uncertainty
around our future trading relationship
with the European Union the sooner the
sooner we can restore certainty the
sooner we can get back onto a path of
solid economic growth I give way to the
honourable gentleman Chancellor for
allowing me to intervene on he's being
very generous with this time can the
Chancellor clarify as to whether the
government's analysis confirms that this
[ __ ] faith brexit deal that the
government offers hearing will actually
leave our country permanently poorer mr.
speaker in in all scenarios we expect
that economic growth will continue and
the country the economy will carry on
growing what we are looking at in the
analysis we published last week is a
ranking order between five different
scenarios of their impact on the overall
size of the economy looking out on a 15
year time horizon mr. speaker that I
will in just a moment let me make a
little progress mr. speaker the theme
for today's debate as you've reminded
the house is the economy and the economy
has always been at the heart of the UK's
relationship with Europe it was
definitely not I was there and I
remember the lure of political union
that brought Britain into the European
Economic Community as it then was in
1973 but the prospect of jobs wage
growth trade and prosperity and for most
of us who campaigned 43 years later to
remain in the EU in 2016 it was
certainly not the political institutions
and the paraphernalia of the union that
provided the motivation to do so but a
hard-nosed appraisal of our economic
interests
the fact is our economic and trading
relationship with the EU has been built
over 45 years and during that time our
economies have shaped themselves around
each other and become inextricably
intertwined supply chains criss cross
borders workforces draw on talent from
across the continent a firm in
Birmingham can deal with a customer in
Berlin as easily as one in Bradford so
much so that almost 65% of all UK trade
is now with the EU or through EU trade
agreements these trading relationships
and commercial partnerships were not
built overnight but in a no deal exit
many of them would be destroyed
overnight as the market access and free
flowing borders on which they are based
were lost and while new trade
partnerships with countries outside the
EU undoubtedly offer new and exciting
opportunities for UK companies the
analysis the government published last
week is clear that the benefits flowing
from new FTAs would not compensate for
the loss of EU trade from a No Deal
exit I give way to my other friend the
Chancellor on Tuesday at the House of
Commons library wrote to me to say that
the back stock comes into force
automatically filled with drol agreement
is signed at the end of the transition
period this morning the Prime Minister
said and I quote if we get to the point
where it might be needed we have a
choice as as to what we do so we don't
even have to go into the backstop at
that point can the Chancellor help
explain that because there seems to be a
variance between those two statements
the backstop remains as the ultimate
default but the agreement we've
negotiated with the European Union very
importantly gives us the choice if we
are not ready to move to our new future
partnership on the 1st of January 2021
gives us a choice to seek an extension
of the implementation period for a
period of one or two further years and
that's a very important part of the
architecture of what we've negotiated I
make no bone
I've said it before in my view it would
be much better for the UK to seek an
extension of the implementation period
if we need a further period of time
before we're ready for the new long-term
arrangements rather than go into the
backstop I give way to the on a big
employment Greg talk to the Chancellor
and he's making a very good case about
what would happen if there was a no deal
brexit indeed in his opening remarks he
described it has enacted uncertainty and
economic self harm given that the
companies he's talked about that depends
so much on just-in-time deliveries in
the motor industry and elsewhere are
most worried most concerned about the
prospect of a no deal brexit mister is
clearly not a majority in this house for
a No Deal brexit what we may disagree
about other things why do we not unite
and rule out that option that mr.
speaker is to support the proposal that
the Prime Minister has presented to the
house which represents a compromise
ensuring that we leave the EU that we
respect the referendum decision of the
British people but we do so in a way
that is designed to minimize any
negative impact on our economy and
maximize the opportunities for this
country in the future I give way to my
honourable friend
I thank my right honourable friend for
giving away things